chuckle Herr general mattis say that he
looks for initiative and aggressiveness
in NCOs I'm not a naturally aggressive
leader
do you believe leader should be
aggressive by nature when when to be
aggressive or when do you be aggressive
does it come off as fake if not if it's
not natural so you know obviously this
is something we talk about all the time
is that thief being default aggressive
is good for leaders yes that is a true
statement there's a dichotomy obviously
because you can be too aggressive and
then things go wrong and things go bad
and things don't work and yes there are
some people that are let's say more
aggressive by nature and then lest also
let's also remember that being
aggressive means a lot more than just
being loud brash and in-your-face right
that is the stereotypical thing that we
think of when we think of all that guys
really aggressive you think this guy's
in-your-face she's yelling he's you know
pushing people over that is not the type
of aggressiveness that you need to be an
effective leader you don't need to be a
loudmouth you don't need to be brash you
don't need to get in people's faces
what being aggressive means is is taking
action that's the kind of aggressiveness
that I'm talking about that's the kind
of aggressive that general mattis is
talking about and you know the
definition actually wrote this down the
definition of of aggressive or one of
the - definitions of being aggressive is
forceful and sometimes overly assertive
pursuit of one's aims so first of all
forceful we get right sometimes overly
assertive some means sometimes that you
have to go a little bit like harder and
here's why that's important because
listen in combat
almost nothing will happen the way you
want it to if you don't force it that
way right you are coming against a
powerful force the enemy nature time
there's all kinds of things that that
are going against you it's a losing
battle and if you don't use force of
will then then then you're not gonna get
it done you have to be aggressive and
make things happen I remember us so
there was a there was we all got
interviewed after we came home from
Ramadi and I remember I was listening to
Seth stone get interviewed and it was
just they were just trying to you know
capture whatever information moments
historical accounts of what had happened
in Ramadi and and Seth said something
along the lines of every operation we
did you could feel jaakko beating his
head against the wall to make things
happen
and I got you know of course I laughed
but from his perspective and it's a good
perspective and it's an accurate
perspective none of this nothing just
kind of oh that fell into my lap that
just doesn't happen it doesn't happen in
combat it just doesn't happen in combat
and so yes this idea that you're gonna
be aggressive is is is very important
but if you think to yourself well okay
okay look I'm not the type of person
that likes to be a loudmouth likes to
shout likes to yell cool good it doesn't
matter you don't need to be that way
what it means is is you need to make
things happen that's what it means and
it can be this is the good thing about
being aggressive sure there's there's
certain parts of your nature that are
aggressive but it can also be trained
you can you can start to think with an
aggressive mindset which is I am going
to take action I'm gonna overcome
obstacles I'm gonna push through
roadblocks I'm not gonna take no for an
answer and those are things that you can
train and and and how do you train them
look when you when you hit an obstacle
you look at it you you know you shake
your head and you go cool let's go let's
figure this out there's so often times
where people they get told no or they
hit an obstacle in it's game over for
they're just done they're done training
they're over it and your attitude you
have to go okay little little robot cool
how am I gonna get through it how many
and I used to put people so to train
people to be more aggressive regardless
of what their pretend believe me I had I
had guys you know steel officers that
were coming through that or sealed
Chiefs that were coming through real
real passive guys quiet guys you know
not in type of person that you would
figure oh that guy's oh yeah that guy's
aggressive you wouldn't characterize him
as that but I would so what I would do
is put them in situations where if they
didn't make aggressive decisions to make
things happen they were gonna get
annihilated put them in training
scenarios like that okay oh you want to
sit here and you want to wait like
you're getting attacked and you want to
sit here and you wonder way you don't
make it one don't want to make a
decision cool in in 16 minutes I will
have everyone in your task unit dead we
will kill them all the paintball
if you end it and so they learn that and
I go what do you think happened you know
and they'd say oh we started to get
surrounded and and I go and what did you
do well you know we we held position
okay how how long do you hold position
for we held it for a while and one of
the enemy do well they started to
maneuver and then what you do
well we held position and then what the
enemy do well they maneuvered more and
then what you do I held position and we
started taking casualties and then the
enemy maneuvered and then they closed
the distance and then they took us out
okay what do you think would have been
better well perhaps when it first
started before they had us enveloped I
could have made a maneuver to get to
another building with some more high
ground that sounds like a great idea
next time why don't you be a little bit
more aggressive in making things happen
okay put him in the same scenario they
get a little bit more aggressive they
realize that it's that it it serves its
function and they start to develop the
attitude they start to understand what a
lack of aggression will get you because
that's an important thing to know right
it's not just a carrot it's the stick
cool if I do if I do this aggressive
thing it'll be rewarding if I don't do
something aggressive we're gonna get
annihilated so here's the other thing
that you got to be ready for so if
you're if you're a person that you lean
towards being passive you've got to
start to lean towards being aggressive
and here's the thing that you got to
remember you're gonna make mistakes
because when you're aggressive you're
taking more risk and often you're taking
more risk now when you if you've played
out the whole matrix of being passive
birth versus being aggressive I will
tell you
being aggressive is the one that ends up
on top are there but there are scenarios
where your aggressiveness ends up
costing you a little bit that absolutely
happens it happens in business it
happens in life it happens on the
battlefield but overall being aggressive
is what this is why this is why that
this is where the idea of you this is
where the idea of aggressive has to be
your default mode this is exactly why
aggression has to be your default mode
your default mode is aggressive if your
default mode is aggressive and it's not
the right answer you just used to use
the other answer right
your default mode is aggressive that's
why I originally said to these young
seal officers your default mode has to
be aggressive so if you're not sure if
you should stay as you go go to the
default which is going to be aggressive
because nine times out of ten seven
times out of ten eight times out of ten
that's gonna be a better move than
sitting on your ass and doing nothing
that's what's gonna get you killed so
your default mode is to go now do you
always go with your default mode no no
you don't always go with it to the
default mode but occasionally you go oh
you know what I'm not gonna go to the
default mode you put it you pull the
setting out and even go into the other
mode customize it customize a little bit
for that particular situation but your
default mode is I'm gonna be aggressive
and that's the the odds you want the
odds you want to stack the odds in your
favor hmm what is it Jason Jason Gardner
says puts it kind of a cool like good
way to just really wrap your head around
like being it default mode something
along the lines of like it's easier it's
better to like have to pull someone back
totally then have to push him forward
yes it's a million times easier to have
to pull the reins in on someone on an
element on a team on a leader on a
person it's it's a million times easier
to go I I hey hey come on back going too
hard it then going hey you need to get
out there yeah because by the way I mean
if you think about this from like an
actual event unfolding if an event
unfolds and you're the person that's on
point and you don't react to it properly
that that event needs to make it through
you
to me before I can now assess what I
think you should do and then tell you to
go do it and then kick you in the ass
there you go do it I don't want that we
already lost yeah I want I want you to
go hey oh we just got this event started
unfolding I'm on it and you look back at
me hey Jocko I'm solving this problem
right now
Oh what's the problem right I don't even
know what the problem is yet you already
solving it that's what I want and if I
happen to occasionally have to pull the
reins on you I'm more than happy to pull
the reins on you what so yes that's a
universal it's easier to lead someone
that you have to pull the reins on then
you have to push we'd rather pull back
then push forward and that that idea of
being aggressive is as part of that so I
want all my I want on all my subordinate
leaders to be aggressive and as a leader
I know that my supporters are going to
make mistakes while they're learning to
be aggressive and even when they're
being aggressive and I'm therefore
considered fully trained and fully ready
they're still gonna make mistakes I'm
still gonna make mistakes being
aggressive I'm gonna make mistakes but
we're gonna play the odds and the odds
are the odds are you be aggressive I'm
trying to think of a good blackjack you
know be you ever play blackjack before
either yeah so I mean like there's you
know dealers showing uh whatever do you
do is showing twenty and you're showing
a fourteen you got to hit it like that
that's the odds the odds are you got to
hit it mm-hmm dealer's showing a
fourteen and you're showing a fourteen
you gotta let the you gotta you gotta
hold let the dealer let the dealer take
the hit do they call it
I forget what do they call it showing
twenty cuz you know one is down one is
up yeah right do they call that showing
twenty have a tanner yeah yeah because
you don't know what the other card is
you just assumed I'd you assume that
it's a so you showing okay yeah and I
haven't played blackjack in a while I
can't I can't believe I'm like
struggling with my thought process
around blackjack around the numbers it
was more of a terminology yeah but you
play the odds
yeah and there's a rules when you're
playing the odds in blackjack there's
rules of yeah what you hit and what you
don't and you stick with the rules the
odds are gonna be in your side yeah
yeah more than if you don't if you just
sit back and that's and so we're playing
the odds
we're playing the odds with leadership
yeah and the odds are you default mode
it's not that you never come out of
default mode the odds are you be
aggressive
so back to this question here listen to
another couple things in this question
when to be aggressive look the default
mode is be aggressive and sometimes you
look at it you'll know now's not the
time does it come off as fake or not
natural hey it's not being aggressive
from this perspective isn't how you're
acting it's the decisions that you're
making
it's the decision I was working with a
client yesterday and we were talking
about data I think it was a client call
it was another yeah it was about data
and it was actually the very similar
question hey um I'm not very aggressive
and I'm more of a data guy and I like
numbers and that's how I roll and yet
I'm not getting recognized and I was
like cool get aggressive with your data
put your data together and present it up
the chain of command not to say hey look
at me but to say hey here's what's going
on here's what I'm doing you're being
aggressive with your data you're showing
them what's happening cuz the guy wasn't
getting the recognition that he needed
right any what so that meant his senior
leadership didn't know what he was doing
which meant he's not getting the
resources that he needs to do his job
and instead of being like hey this is
what I need cuz he's not an aggressive
guy he's sitting back and just getting
resources stripped away from him I said
cool you're a data guy record the data
of what you're doing
present it and the dad let the data
speak get default aggressive with your
data did I miss anything here yeah so
it's not natural yeah I mean I mean if
you all of a sudden start to try and act
yeah you know this this new way yeah
it's it's it's probably not gonna go
good now can you do you sometimes have
to learn like okay you know what I gotta
stand up and say something I gotta put
word out right yeah you know and I
watched many guys in my career go
through the transition of being a little
bit less aggressive and they realize you
know what I'm in charge of this thing I
gotta go put the word out and and that's
perfectly fine yeah you know those kind
of for like about a superficial
personality traits that are aggressive
some people say oh well that's
that aggressive yes you know where
there's more depth to it
we're like because again like you know
you can think of like a I don't know
some fictional or maybe not in fact not
fictional like maybe Japanese
business tycoon who doesn't say nothing
really no but you know he's making
aggressive moves like that's an
aggressive guy kind of it goes deep and
then you know a guy who you are you're
saying like he yells and screams and has
a loud voice or whatever it's kind of
okay if that's your personality that's
gonna land for sure but it's more about
the decisions you make even say it's
gonna land what do you mean because that
might just make a bunch of people Hank
right right some type ends on what
you're yelling and screaming - sure what
you're saying is there could be someone
that's loud at scream but they're but
they're they're using that to cover the
fact that they're actually not making
any move essentially you see yeah so the
yelling and screaming has very little do
with aggressive movement on the
battlefield yeah he's what I'm saying oh
I'm saying there's more depth to it but
the point actually is is that um you
should have just taken that point cuz
that was a good point you know taking
that one wrong but I want to continue
this was a probably less chlorophyll but
nonetheless if you if because he's
concerned about faking it or coming off
with his fing we're know if you're
focused on those like a superficial
elements of your personality being
aggressive that's the part they're gonna
smell is fake if you're trying to change
that part of sure you know like whoa
this probably used to have this tea in
seventh grade is I don't know I think
it's like a music teacher know something
super aggressive mutant alter he was
like a nice dude like really nice
there's not too many stereotypical hyper
aggressive music teachers no man he
wasn't I had I had an assistant platoon
commander and aggressive great guy and
he you know I didn't I you know as I got
to know him you know and I was like so
would you study in college and he's like
percussion yeah dang it were you talking
about
I was like what concussion why he's like
percussion drumming user draw
he started drumming in college which is
just kind of deep in percussion yeah I
didn't know you could major in
percussion I mean I guess but anyways
history of percussion yeah
properties of percussion my point is had
he become a music teacher
humidity cuz use the rest of the system
for tune commander yeah had if I had to
pull the reins on him we'll be out there
getting after it
this guy was not aggressive at all he
was like a nice guy trying to please
everyone you know short term and long
term kind of thing which didn't really
work with me I'm pretty sure was seventh
grade so he was like I remember guys we
just run circles around him you know
like people wouldn't listen at all so he
had trouble controlling the class we'll
say that and then I wanted one time he
tried to switch his personality yeah one
time he dropped the book you know how
like sometimes when you drop a book yes
sometimes when he hits correctly it's
like boom it's like oh [ __ ] so one time
Brad he tried to do that and it didn't
make the sound and like no one it was
like what the [ __ ] is this guy doing
he's like looking everybody with his
eyes all big nonetheless I think that
was like I think he got aggressive one
day and people like shut up and we're
like hey this guy's like you know how on
someone's never aggressive then they
start yelling you're like everyone kind
of be quiet yeah angas yelling so I
think he might have got a small little
payoff one day and then from then on he
started to try to be like aggressive
everyone could smell it on like Brad
that's not even your thing so he's gotta
be working against them yeah everyone
was kind of laughing at I'm not now he's
like a weirdo yep so no no no no need to
do that we throw on the music book on
the table
big textbook is on the floor too yeah it
didn't work for ch